Essentially, life is a game.
There are natural and manmade laws that serve
as rules.
There is a beginning and an end.
There is a game board we play on that we call
planet earth.
And there are decisions and moves that we
make that determine where and how we move
on the board.
Of course, we all want to win.
Some of us do, and some of us don’t.
But that begs the question, how DOES one win?
Unlike a normal game, there is no time after
life for us to bask in and enjoy a victory.
And so, if we wish to truly experience wining
the game of life, we must frame our definition
of how we win accordingly, so that we win
while the game is still in play.
Winning the game of life is not predicated
merely by the quantity of material successes
that we have accumulated by the end of it.
Sure, it is enjoyable and important to acquire
things within the game of life, but the accumulation
of things like wealth, material excess, fame,
or status tend to easily be confused as the
ultimate endgame.
But they are not.
They are just parts of the game.
And furthermore, each win of this kind is
generally short lived.
It is just like how winning a board game,
video game, or sports game might feel good
when it occurs and for a little while after,
but the feeling soon fades and you return
to your normal state.
And so it is important that the state that
you return to in life is a victory in it of
itself.
In the case of the game of life, not only
is the sense of fulfillment from material
wins short lived, but the accumulation of
material points does not matter much at the
end of it.
These points don’t go anywhere with you
when you are dead and gone.
Instead, it is about how much you enjoyed
the game of pursuing the points in the first
place.
Ironically, you truly win the game of life
when you realize and embrace that it IS a
game.
When you become aware that against all odds,
you were somehow rendered into this existence
and are now able to play and enjoy the most
enthralling, sophisticated, and entertaining
game ever to exist.
A game that is so complex and uncertain that
you can never completely predict what’s
going to happen next.
A game that is always updating.
A game that you can come up with rules for,
change existing ones, unlock new levels, and
uncover hidden settings.
And the quality of your life experience truly
maximizes when you realize that you have already
won by being able to do any
of this.